why do we get the seasons the seasons
because of the atmosphere to be honest
with you that's a very easy question to
answer now we really don't get seasons
anymore because of global warming and I
think there was a time when I was a
child where we definitely had four
seasons I think now we get summer summer
summer and a little bit of winter in
Australia is it to do with them there is
turning and the equator for seasons but
there
you mean like summer and winter yeah
autumn and spring does not come from
where we are around the Sun and at that
stage that's the season that we're in I
think the position of the earth
depending on the Sun it's like if it
were sustaining other positions to the
earth and there is winter summer and in
the between it is autumn and what is
that spring because the Earth rotates on
an axes are and I think so it goes or as
an accident well obviously the earth
isn't like spinning what like that it's
sort of like on an angle because of the
axis of the earth rotated the earth
rotating around its axis yeah what does
the access to it saves you further and
closer to the Sun for example now the
southern part Australian is a winter now
and Europe is in the summer season and
then the north side of the earth is
spending more close to the to the Sun
and the south side is like far away from
that it's because the earth is at I
think it's a 22 degree tilt or something
like that so as it goes round the Sun
that means that either the North or the
southern hemisphere is close to the Sun
so that um things are hotter or colder
when when the earth Quran is on it's not
a circle as an ellipse
you have different distance to there son
so therefore the furthest Sun is a way
to colder days
country let's cuz it's like in overall
it's not like things that we shuttle
fact so the Sun comes closer this way
and the elliptical pattern of the earth
and the distance from motor to the Sun
in turn for the farthest away from it in
the winter
you
sometimes the Sun is actually glancing
the surface of the earth in certain
regions and other times it's square on
like perpendicular basically the sun's
rays are more oblique at certain times
of the year than others I think it's
because of how the sun rays like hitting
when they hit at an angle it doesn't get
that hot